Hey people welcome to the podcast
Joshua Fields Millburn and Ryan Nicodemus,
AKA The Minimalists, are in the house dropping truths
on how to live better with less.
I love these guys.
I've known them for years.
So much respect for their mission, their work,
empowering millions of people all over the world.
This conversation is stellar,
potentially even life altering.
So with that being said, hit the subscribe button and enjoy.
What's up, guys?
What's up?
This is a long time in the making.
Yeah
It's good to have you here.
Great to see both of you.
Good to be had.
Joshua's hair is looking perfect as always.
Always.
You know, Joshua gets a lot of attention for his hair
and this whole Christopher Walken thing,
but not enough attention is paid to your hair, Ryan.
You have excellent hair
I'm sort of between you guys
My hair looks horrible today.
I cut my hair.
I had long hair like yours.
But you're looking fabulous today as well.
Thanks, man.
You know, I felt like I was having a bad hair day today
so that really uplifts my spirits.
So thank you very much
It's all good, man.
It's all good.
People who've been on this podcast journey for a while
will likely remember a podcast that I did
with Joshua way back in the day.
But Ryan, this is your first time here.
I was boycotting you at the time.
Yeah, I don't know what was going on between us,
but we worked it out.
You guys have been gracious enough to host me
on your show several times.
And I'm delighted to have you here
on the eve of your new documentary coming out.
That's exciting, man.
Thanks so much
Thanks for having us.
Yeah, it's cool.
I'm excited to be
here too, man.
Your story is well told, but I think it would be good
to at least contextualize everything
we're gonna talk about
by sharing your personal stories.
And also in particular Ryan,
since yours, you haven't had an opportunity
to share yours here.
So how do we launch into that?
What's the best place to start?
Should we start at the beginning?
Yeah, 1981. (all chuckle)
Fifth grade, best friends.
I think we should start with Josh.
Two pudgy kids sitting in the corner.
Yeah, exactly.
Plotting world domination.
That's not far from the truth
except the world domination part.
It was more like
the suburbs
You were working your way
towards it
of Dayton domination.
Working our way towards it.
How many kids from Dayton have documentaries on Netflix?
I mean, the Wright brothers.
Yeah.
The Wright brothers, okay, all right
So there's them.
Who's the other?
Martin sheen, he is from.
I don't think there's a doc though.
No.
He might be in a documentary.
Here's where we start, I think.
I'll tee it up.
So Ryan and I grew up really poor in Dayton, Ohio.
We've known each other, as you said,
since we were fat little fifth graders
and literally I was the fattest kid in school.
Ryan was the second fattest kid
It's so hard to believe,
but when you watch the documentary,
you're like, wow, he was telling the truth.
Yeah, I mean, it was impressive or depressive.
Anyway, we knew each other.
We grew up really poor, dysfunctional homes,
before that term dysfunctional was in vogue
and we were pretty discontented growing up.
And of course we thought, well, how do we become happy?
And of course that was make money.
And so we climbed the corporate ladder
throughout our twenties
and had ostensibly successful careers.
But of course we weren't successful.
We were overwhelmed and stressed
and sort of discontented by the lives we created.
And you know, what's fascinating now,
Ryan, is the the life we were living growing up,
it was so chaotic.
We traded that chaos just for a different type of chaos.
Controlled chaos it's still chaos.
In fact, it's an oxymoron.
And so yeah, we were working in corporate America
making really good money, spending even better money.
And so had massive amounts of debt
and knew we needed to make a change.
Well, yeah.
I mean, you both grew up
in alcoholic households, essentially, right?
Yeah.
Food stamps, poverty.
So it's not surprising that you would seek out security
and an upward kind of financially secure trajectory.
I mean, that's what most people would do
trying to emerge out of a situation like that.
Yeah, I just, I remember working
for my dad just out of high school.
He just had like small painting and wallpaper company
and he worked his butt off and he made nothing
and now I was there working my butt off making nothing.
And I'm like, I know there's a way I can work
just as hard but make more money.
And that's when I went into Telecom with Josh.
And yeah, like he said,
I started making really awesome money.
And I thought, oh, I figured it out.
I finally figured it out.
I remember, 'cause even during high school
I worked for my dad painting and hanging wallpaper.
And I remember early on when I was working for him
we were in this really nice house.
It wasn't like a mansion or anything,
but it was like something nicer
than my mom or dad had ever owned.
And I looked at my dad, I'm like,
"This is a really nice place, man.
"Like how much do I need to make in order to live here?"
And he's like, "If you can make $50,000 a year
"you could probably afford a place like this."
So for me, that was like, yeah,
that was the number for happiness, $50 grand a year.
And when I went to the Telecom company,
I think that very first year
I made like $52,000 or something.
And I was really proud of myself
and happy that I was making more money.
I went out and bought a new truck
I guess it wasn't technically mine,
'cause you know, I got a loan,
got a car payment basically, but I wasn't happy.
And I realized why I wasn't happy.
It was because I didn't adjust for inflation.
The $50,000 number had grown a little bit.
So I'm like, oh, maybe it's $60,000,
maybe it's $80,000, maybe it's six figures
or maybe just owning a bunch of stuff.
So yeah, that's what I pursued.
But I mean, my story really with minimalism,
it kind of starts with Josh
because when we were in the corporate world,
we were miserable.
We had accumulated so many different burdens.
Whether it's debt or whether it's an overabundance
of clutter,
whether it was chasing a job title.
I mean it was very, very depressing.
But I noticed Josh who started being
a little bit less depressed
and that's when I went to him
and I asked him like,
"Hey man, what are you doing that's making you so happy?
"Why the hell are you so happy?"
And that's when he introduced this thing
called minimalism into my life.
Well, walk me up to the point of this epiphany Joshua.
'Cause I think it's important to understand
the inflection point that introduced you
to this new way of living.
Sure, yeah.
My mom died and my marriage ended both in the same month.
And so it was like sort of this double car crash.
It's like you get hit by one thing
and then it swerves you into this other thing.
And at the same time, my corporate career,
I was really discontented by it.
I was managing 150 retail stores,
which I know is ironic with the whole minimalism thing now,
but maybe it took that in a way for me to recalibrate.
But these two big events happened to me
and I started questioning everything.
And literally every thing,
the things in my life, especially
because I had spent the last dozen years,
I was 30 at the time,
and as I began questioning those things in my life
I realized that I had worked so hard
to buy a bunch of things to make me happy
and those things aren't doing their job.
And so they had become my priority though.
And so of course my priorities were totally
out of whack, achievement, success.
Now it's not that Ryan and I are
against material possessions,
and we don't think it's morally wrong to own things.
We own stuff.
I got here in a car today.
I have a bed and a couch.
Wearing a nice jacket.
Yeah, thank you.
A lot of money spent on hair products.
(all laughing)
But the thing is
I had such an attachment to the things
but also the perception of other people
and a lot of that had to do with ego.
And so ultimately what I figured out at the time
was, oh, my priorities are really out of whack.
And thankfully I stumbled across minimalism,
thanks to the internet at the time.
Someone tweeted Colin Wright, a friend of ours,
who was in our first minimalism documentary.
And he lived with 52 items.
And I didn't aspire to that,
but it made me realize there was a relatively normal person
doing very abnormal things.
And I didn't want to live his life
but that exposed me to a bunch of other minimalists,
people like Leo Babauta, Courtney Carver, and Joshua Becker,
more normal people who had like families and houses.
Leo's got like five kids or something like that.
Six
Six.
Yeah.
He didn't even have the condoms,
he was so minimalist
What's interesting about this
to me is you could have,
given a different set of circumstances,
ended up at a Buddhist monastery or joining the Peace Corps.
Clearly you were having an existential crisis
about how you were living.
You had premised your entire life on this idea
that this very traditional upward corporate trajectory
would deliver on its promise of making you happy.
You achieve those things.
You're lacking that sense
of connection that you thought it would deliver
and you go searching, and you stumble upon minimalism.
But what if it had been some other thing?
There are other paths to sort of finding
a little bit more fulfillment and purpose,
but you, for whatever reason,
minimalism was the thing that you connected with.
Yeah and by the way, I think that I connected with it
because there wasn't a particular dogma
among the people that I saw.
There wasn't a 12 step thing.
And I look at a lot of the stuff now on
Don't you dare talk bad on the 12 step thing.
No, no, no, no.
Go ahead.
No, I know I'm just kidding.
I'm not talking
about 12 steps
But like the five steps to declutter your closet.
And so it wasn't, the how to side of things
wasn't that appealing to me,
it was the why to side of things
that really made me scrutinize what I was doing.
Even now you won't see me and Ryan
talk about the 17 ways to declutter your kitchen.
We're not gonna do a video about that.
If someone else wants to do that, that's fine.
I don't think that actually addresses the problem.
I think those types of solutions,
they often cause new problems
because we begin to focus on,
we turn those things into the main focus
and it removes our focus
from whatever the underlying problem is.
And so I was fascinated by what these people were doing
and how they were doing it,
but I was much more focused on the why.
That's why the new film, Less Is Now,
it really starts with that question.
How might your life be better with less?
Now that's a how question, but it's a disguised question.
It's actually a why question.
You see that in the anecdotes
and the stories of the kind of everyday people
that have undergone this process
and how it's emotionally changed their lives
or their perspective on how they live day to day.
But it is true.
And we've talked about this before
that on a surface level
it's about getting rid of your stuff
but it's really not about that at all.
And I think a lot of the focus
or the kind of news narrative around it
is around decluttering,
but the process of decluttering
is really just a way to clear space
so you can marshal your awareness
onto the things that are important
that you want to focus on.
Is that fair or accurate?
Yeah, no, I think that is totally fair.
It's interesting though.
It makes me think how the media
wants to sell a solution to a symptom
rather than address the problem.
I mean, that doesn't really speak to what you're asking.
Well, the problem is so massive
and we're all living amidst this grand delusion.
Our entire society is founded upon the idea
that you played out in your own life
and had to figure out for yourselves,
wasn't delivering on the promise.
This idea that we should be seeking security,
and comfort, and salary increases, and the new car,
and all the messages that bombard us
everywhere we turn our head reinforces that.
And yet what it doesn't do,
and the movie does a beautiful job of illustrating this,
is remind us about what's most important
which is community and the connection
to the people that we love
and pursuing your life with some level of intentionality.
Yeah, absolutely.
Well, I mean, Annie Leonard talks
about this in the documentary about deficit advertising.
So advertisers, big corporations, whatever,
they go out of their way to make you feel
like you're missing something in your life.
So that's why we chase the bigger paycheck.
So we can go out and buy those things
that subconsciously we're like, oh man,
if I just had like a little bit of a nicer car
I'd have a better ride to work,
and I'd enjoy my commute a little bit more.
And if I just a little bit bigger of a house,
I could have that Pilates studio.
And I mean, yeah.
You just notch it up, and then you get there.
And then you're like, well, I don't feel that way yet,
but it's because there's a guy
who's living a little bit higher
up on the Hill than I am.
Yeah, by the way
I don't want to moralize any of this either.
I don't want to say it's better or worse
to own fewer possessions.
I'm not saying that it's good
that Ryan and I own less than we used to own.
I'm not saying it's bad either.
It is probably more appropriate for us,
given the constraints.
But to the point you were asking about, Rich,
our material possessions are sort of
this physical manifestation of what's going on inside us.
That's that existential crisis you talked about.
And so the external clutter is a way
that we sort of visualize the mental clutter,
or the psychological clutter, or the emotional clutter
the spiritual clutter, this internal clutter.
And we found that like with minimalism,
yeah, we could have been Buddhism or Christianity
or anything else that we would have stumbled into
but stumbling into minimalism allowed us
to deal with the thing that had become
this priority in our lives.
Stuff had become this priority.
And so it started with the stuff
but that's sort of the initial bite at the apple.
And then it goes to simplifying all other areas of life.
But there's this moment that you experienced
and that you see in the people profiled in the film
where the lights kind of go on,
as they begin this process,
there's like an and enervating that occurs in their lives.
Like they become very emotionally involved
in the process of decluttering their lives
and it becomes exciting,
and there's a momentum that kind of occurs.
Yeah, you're talking about the everyday minimalists
that we have in our film.
Yeah, no, it is encouraging.
There's one gentleman in there
who talks about how once he started simplifying
and got to where he felt like he wasn't
living in a bunch of clutter,
he kind of realized, oh, I've had everything
I ever needed this whole time.
He gets emotional.
And he's an older guy, he's not like a millennial.
Yeah, absolutely.
No, I love having those kind of everyday minimalists
in there to kind of talk about their own
personal experiences,
especially because Josh and I,
we can tell her stories all day long,
but you need other people to resonate with
than just two dudes with really great hair.
It is really great though.
We didn't want it to be the Josh and Ryan story.
Like the first film, Minimalism,
it was sort of exposing people
to different ideas of intentional living
and different areas of minimalism.
There were minimalist architects
and there are Buddhists, et cetera.
In this film, we didn't want it to just be,
oh, Josh and Ryan tell their story
but it sort of circled around that initial story of us.
But we brought in some experts
but then we also had 30 of those everyday minimalist.
So we wanted all these different perspectives.
You probably noticed the diversity in the film
but it's not just like an ethnic diversity.
It's like we have a 17 year old
and a 70 year old in the film.
And all we did was we put a call out
and said, hey, does anyone have a story
about how they've been affected by our first film,
and they've simplified their lives?
And how did that work out for you?
And we just started bringing those people into the film.
So taking it back, you have this experience
in the wake of your marriage dissolving
and your mother's passing,
where you decide that you're gonna basically
change your lifestyle top to bottom.
You get rid of all this stuff,
you have that light's going on experience.
You seem lighter in your shoes.
I assume you're still at the job at that point
but you were just showing up
with a little bit of a bigger smile.
Yeah, I was also doing a better job
setting expectations.
So we were on call like doctors,
but I wasn't saving anyone.
I couldn't even save myself.
And yet I had to answer the phone at 10:00 PM
if my boss' boss wanted to know something
about the sales transactions for any of the stores that day.
So it was a regular occurrence.
The last thing I did when my head hit the pillow
was check my Blackberry.
The first thing when I got up in the morning
And throughout the day, all throughout the day,
I was checking and I started setting expectations.
And that was sacrilegious where we worked.
I called my boss, said,
"I'm not gonna take phone calls in the evening anymore."
And I could audibly hear his jaw drop
on the phone because, what do you mean?
You realized that he didn't realize that was an option,
even for himself.
I got a call from our boss.
We had the same boss.
And he was like, "Is Josh, like, is he depressed?
"Like maybe planning on killing himself or something?"
'Cause I'm giving away my stuff.
Giving away his stuff.
He's saying, hey, I don't care what you think.
I'm not taking phone calls at six.
But isn't that kind of sad
that that's the reaction though.
Yeah.
As opposed to, wow, is he doing something
that changes his life
so that he experiences more peace or more contentment?
Like I said, I don't think this is an indictment on stuff
or even on corporate America.
It's an indictment on chasing, on craving, on attachment.
Well, also on your relationship to externalities.
Yeah.
So, Ryan, at some point you began
to cotton on to this,
like what's going on with Joshua, right?
Yeah, I mean, it was after him setting boundaries.
It was after that phone call from our boss
because I did not see a depressed Josh.
I saw someone who was taking control
of something that he had no control over.
And it wasn't until,
so he moved into a new place
after he split up with his wife.
And it was like a two bedroom, one bath or maybe two baths,
but it was only half full.
But the one thing that was missing
that really stood out to me was the TV.
And every time I'd go over, I'd be like,
dude when are you getting a TV?
What kind of TV are you gonna get?
Because that's how we compared success
in the corporate world.
What kind of TV you got at your house?
How many TVs do you have?
How big is that TV?
I wonder what Freud would say about this.
So at a certain point, he's like,
"I don't think I'm gonna get a TV."
I'm like, interesting.
And yeah, eventually I wanted whatever he was doing.
And when he said minimalism, I don't know,
you asked that in the beginning
about would it have been a different path,
could it have been a different path
if we didn't find minimalism.
Well, if he shaved his head
and disappeared to a monastery for a while and came back,
maybe you wouldn't have been so.
Yeah, probably not.
Probably not.
But he introduced the term minimalism to me
and to be honest, if it was someone else
I don't know how seriously I would have taken it,
but him and I have very, it's weird,
we have like exact opposite Myers-Briggs personalities
but we have very similar personalities in other ways.
So I was like, if this works for him
I'll at least give it a shot
and look at it and see if it'll work for me.
So the first video he sent me was Colin Wright
with the 50 things that he owned.
And I'm like, oh okay, this is a little weird.
But then I got into other minimalists,
Courtney, Carver, Leo Babauta, Joshua Becker.
And you know, what I saw is common sense.
I saw a lot of people talking
about all these common sense things that I knew internally
but for some reason I never listened to.
And minimalism for me,
it was an opportunity for me to start over.
It was an opportunity for me to,
well, do what Josh did and gain control
of what I had lost control over.
So I got really excited.
I'm like, dude, I want to be a minimalist.
This is awesome.
I get it, what should I do?
So you do this packing party thing, basically.
Yeah, exactly.
So in the excitement, he was like,
"Well, what if we pack up all your stuff
"and then unpack it as you need it."
And I'm like, "That's a great idea"
Especially 'cause I'm a very extreme person
when it comes to things.
Like Josh had pared down over several months.
He made some very slow changes over months time.
But for me, like I needed faster results.
So the packing party was perfect for me.
I think probably most of your listeners right now
I don't know if the packing party
would be the best option for them,
especially if they've got families and stuff.
Although we have totally seen families do.
Well, yeah, I'll say this.
Everyone's at home thinking
of interesting things to do.
There's a lot of people rearranging the furniture
in their houses right now,
losing their minds.
That's a really good idea.
This is like the perfect time
for them to confront all this stuff.
The one time you're really confronted with everything,
like truly confronted, is when you move to a new house.
And so that was sort of the impetus
of the packing party idea, was like,
when you move, you actually have to go through
everything you own and do something with it,
whether it's store it, box it up,
whatever, it doesn't matter.
You have to do something with that stuff.
And now is sort of the second time where this has happened
where people have been in their homes
for way more than they anticipated.
And we thought at the beginning of this
like people were reaching out to us like,
hey, you guys, you're probably upset
that you got rid of all that stuff, aren't you,
now that we're stuck at home?
And I'm like, yeah, the broken waffle iron
is really, I'm missing that right now.
The third bread maker that I got as a wedding gift.
And so anyway that packing party,
we've had dozens of people do it.
In fact, we have a book coming out next year,
called Love People, Use Things.
It's like the whole sort of synopsis of our message.
And in that book we had 47 different families
do a packing party.
So it may seem radical, but it's not so radical
that, I mean, we've had a lot of people do it.
The idea being, you pack everything up
and then you slowly unpack
and deliberately decide which items
you actually need to use
and the rest gets donated or sold.
Right, yeah, I mean, Josh had asked me, he's like,
"What if you unpacked things as you needed it?
"that would really help."
And I'm like, "Yeah, that's a great idea.
"That's what we should do."
And so you can imagine, yeah, my clothes for work,
bed and bed sheets, toothbrush, so forth and so on.
But I'll tell you, the packing party,
it was something to like change my state.
But I honestly didn't realize how powerful
that was going to be until it was over
and I was confronted with all my things.
And the biggest revelation was I had this dream
of retiring early,
but I had like very little in my retirement accounts.
But here I saw tens of thousands of dollars
that I wasn't using worth of stuff.
And I'm like, hmm, that could probably
be sitting in my retirement account right now.
But I remember going to Josh, I'm like,
"Dude, we have to do a website
"and talk about this packing party.
"'Cause this is something."
So that was the original impetus to start the blog.
Yeah.
It started 10 years ago yesterday.
I know.
I saw an Instagram, your 10 year,
you guys have been doing this for 10 years.
It's wild.
10 years, yeah.
That's unbelievable, man.
What's the difference between your relationship
to minimalism then in the early days to now?
Like how has it evolved or changed?
I think it's changed quite a bit recently.
I've become more allergic
to the sort of how to side of things.
I've never been a giant fan of it,
but I've realized that it's actually,
before I was somewhat neutral on it.
It just wasn't for me.
But now I think it's often a problem.
And I think it's an opiate in a way because it helps,
as Ryan alluded to earlier, the sort of the symptoms.
Like if I show you how to declutter your kitchen
but you don't know why you're doing it,
it's gonna be re cluttered a month from now.
And so getting a deep understanding,
if you understand the why, truly understand the why,
the how will take care of itself.
And so we'll talk about some
of the how stuff that we've done,
that may not be applicable for everyone, by the way.
My why looks different from Ryan's why
and that's why starting out with that question,
how might your life be better with less
is really the the foundation of it.
Then we can talk about the how to.
But it's the process,
it's the how that opens the portal to the why.
Like if you're living your life
in a certain way with blinders on
and just moving in a particular direction,
it's very hard to answer that question of why.
You got to shake things up and do something different
in order to kind of confront that.
Short of you doing the packing party,
would you have been, if confronted with the why question,
how are you gonna answer that?
So it's almost like there needs to be
a deconstruction of your life a little bit
and there's some practicalities that
get baked into that.
I'm all for that
It's interesting.
It's almost like the why was so much
in my face at the time of how miserable I was.
It was like
But also you're holding onto it so hard
because your whole life
was invested in that.
Oh 100%.
Yeah, but if it wasn't for that amount of,
or that level of stress and discontent and depression,
I don't know if I would have.
'Cause the problem is sometimes.
Pain is the lever.
Yeah and comfort is like,
I don't know, comfort to me is,
don't get me wrong, I like being comfortable, but
It's fuel for denial.
Absolutely.
The thing I look at with what Ryan
I think Ryan is actually the perfect example
of if you understand the why,
the how it takes care of itself.
No one gave him a how to,
there was not a prescription for a packing party ever.
It didn't exist.
What did exist were a bunch
of decluttering tips and other things
that we had seen for decades
and never paid any attention to,
because that's not that compelling.
It's compelling in the moment at the checkout line,
the same way candy is appealing at the checkout line.
But it's not nutritious in any way.
And so when Ryan truly understood the why,
like, oh, I don't feel at peace, I feel chaos,
let me sort through this.
Let me not fix it because nothing is fixed.
There's always change.
It's not about fixing something,
it's about addressing the problem.
I think that's what the packing party did.
It was the impetus.
Now, yeah, we talk about the how,
but Ryan always talk about how what we share
is like a recipe and you can sort of tweeze out
your own ingredients and create your own version of it,
adjust for taste.
So how long after this packing party
and this decision to write about these things
before you guys are no longer working
at the corporation?
Like I know you got laid off.
I got laid off, yeah, months after Josh.
Josh technically got laid off too.
I laid myself off.
He did.
It was, well, they came to me.
So this was 10 years ago as well.
And they came to me right before Christmas said,
as soon as we finish out the holiday shopping season,
which by the way,
we've turned the holiday season into a shopping season.
Think about that for a moment.
But they said, as soon as we do this,
I need you to close eight stores and lay off 42 employees.
I had done this a bunch of times.
It was never fun, but it got easier over time.
So I laid off a bunch of people and fired people.
It wasn't that big of a deal.
But then with this new perspective
I had been simplifying my life that entire year.
They said you got two weeks to put together this plan,
give us the 42 names that you're going to lay off.
And so I went home and within two days
I was putting the spreadsheets together.
But looking at the spreadsheet was like looking
at a rainbow in black and white and gray scale.
Because these were just names and statistics.
And I get that's how you're going to
make a decision like this.
But these weren't just names.
These were husbands and fathers and daughters and mothers.
And these were people.
And you know, my livelihood was in their hands.
And I knew that like there was some sort of discontent
but at that point I realized the corporation
we were at no longer aligned with my personal values.
And so I turned the plan in,
my name was the first name on the list.
So you really did lay yourself off.
Yeah.
Wow.
And I didn't really, I didn't have a plan.
I just had reduced my bills so significantly
living in Dayton Ohio, $500 a month apartment.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna try this writing thing out for a while.
There was a coffee shop in my neighborhood,
they actually ended up in the documentary.
Press.
Press, yeah.
And I said, I'll just work there
and I'll have enough money to pay my bills.
And I'll write for the rest of the time.
I wanted to write fiction initially.
Thanks to Ryan, this was a beautiful accident
in a different direction.
So you guys start meeting at Press,
you start working on this blog.
I mean, that's what we did for the first year.
We just wrote on the blog and yeah,
put our thoughts out there.
Was there a moment, like a tipping point moment
with the blog where you're like, wow,
this could be a thing.
We could actually craft a vocation around this?
What is the tipping point.
I think for me, it's the San Francisco event.
For me, it was before that.
It was before that?
Yeah, for me it was Leo Babauta
shared something that we did.
I was reading his blog back then too.
That was like, everyone was reading his stuff.
And we had like more people show up in one day.
And it wasn't a lot of people,
it was like 9,000 people or something.
For me, it was like, oh, we haven't seen,
so we talk about this in the film,
how like 52 readers that first month turned into 500,
which turned into 5 million or whatever.
And so there was a moment there,
but around that same time, it was like,
hey, you guys are The Minimalists, aren't you?
Did you write a book about minimalism?
And it's like, oh, I guess we should do that, huh?
We are the minimalists.
And so we did, we put out a book.
At the time we just self published a book
at the end of our first year.
And we went on tour, but it was really just,
we went around the country to coffee shops.
And it made me realize like,
oh, if we can get eight people to show up
and buy a book.
Most stops were like two to eight people.
Yeah.
If we sell 10 books
When you're living minimally,
you don't need much.
No exactly.
If we could sell 10 books.
Then we have a place to stay for the night.
If not, then we'd just sleep in Ryan's Toyota Corolla.
And that's how it worked out for us.
Well, the first movie did such a great job
at spinning that yarn of you guys going on the road
and showing up at places
and three people would show up.
And then slowly a few more, a few more,
and you see the build.
But it's the grittiness of the early days
that was so fun.
I'm just thinking about that South by event
in that minimalism documentary
because I remember being so excited
for that South by Southwest event, like, we made it.
We finally, we finally.
It's a buddy movie road trip on
like a wizard of Oz movie with South by Southwest
being you guys going to meet Oz.
And I was thinking, this was like the apex of our journey.
Like we were at South by Southwest,
this is, and then like, yeah, three people showed up to it.
And they're like on their phones,
by the way, it's 8:00 a.m. on a Sunday morning,
Ryan is trying to talk about living with less.
I'm like, hi everybody.
Yeah, that was great.
Lanyards.
This big room with like three people in it.
Well, that movie is so well done.
And I have to imagine that that had to be
life-changing in some regard.
I think it's most people's introduction to your work
because Netflix put it right out front.
And so many people watched it.
The first question I have about that first movie
is how did you connect with Matt D'Avella?
'Cause Matt D'Avella, he's had his own crazy trajectory
blowing up on YouTube
and being this massive creator on that platform.
100%.
He's all grown up.
We connected with him on Twitter
when he was a wedding videographer.
And I saw this video he made
called Most Wedding Videographers Suck.
And I still bring that up to him constantly
but he was doing that
and he was doing like other commercial work
for like Toyota or Subaru or something.
And we hired him to do the trailer
for our second book, Everything That Remains.
And we did an event out in New York
to sort of celebrate this.
And he filmed that event and made a trailer
for that book that we put up on YouTube.
And that was sort of it.
And then a few months later, I said,
"Hey, we're getting ready to go on the road."
2014, we did a hundred city tour.
And said, "Hey, do you want to come
"on the road with us and try to make a documentary?"
And he had been wanting to do something
with his creative skills other than commercial work.
And so he's like, "Yeah, I'll give it a shot."
At the end of the tour it was like,
he just had a few hard drives
with like a thousand hours of footage.
It was like, hey, good luck with that.
So he just went away and came back
with a cut for you guys?
Yeah.
I remember dropping him off at the airport
and I just remember thinking to myself,
I don't think this is a movie.
I'm like, I have no idea how he's gonna pull this together.
There was no budget for it.
I mean, we were just passionate about it,
so it's not like we had a lot to lose
but then he sent that first cut,
and yeah, I was instantly like, oh wow.
Matt knows what he's doing.
And I always make sure and tell people that
because people will come up to me and they'll be like,
"Oh, you're the guy from the minimalism documentary.
"Great doc.
"You did such a good job."
And I'm like, I wish I could say it was me
but it's really Matt D'Avella
who did that whole documentary.
He did an unbelievable job
and all the accolades and success that he's he's enjoying
on YouTube are well-deserved.
Oh yeah,
Heck yeah.
What he does is amazing on YouTube.
And he has built up this amazing following,
especially if young people, who really,
he's brought the message of minimalism
to a crowd that that maybe Ryan and I
weren't ever going to reach either.
Yeah absolutely.
He makes these like mini documentaries.
I know every one of his videos is like,
should enjoy a theatrical release.
I'm going to tell him that compliment
next time I see him.
Yeah, and he's a guy
who walks the talk, like he just this past week
gave away all his stuff yet again.
And him and his wife are on the road and now in Sydney,
like they're just gonna travel.
They literally, everything they own
is in like little carry on suitcases.
It's a beautiful example of how you can
turn your life around on a dime
when you have the power to let go
of anything in your life.
And I mean, that's exactly what he displayed with that.
'Cause minimalism is not about owning nothing.
It's just about breaking free
from that attachment, breaking free from that,
I don't know another word for it.
Just that attraction that we all have for stuff.
There's a sense that, oh,
if you're going to be a minimalist,
that you're self-flagellating
or you're some kind of martyr,
when in truth you're just purchasing freedom for yourself.
Absolutely, absolutely.
And choices.
To be able to, you know, self-employment is such a gift,
but it gives him with the things that he does,
the ability to just pack it up and go wherever he wants,
which is unbelievable.
And when you see him work, it's amazing.
You wouldn't think he's able to,
he has the strangest sort of,
he's like hiding under the table,
looking up with the camera.
You're like, what is he doing?
Is that a crotch shot?
I'm not sure what's going on here.
But somehow he just
And a total one man show.
When I did his, I was one of the early guests on his podcast
and he's got all these cameras,
and he's doing it all himself.
He's manning the cameras, he's asking the questions.
He's got the monitor there.
I'm like, this looks stressful.
Like, get a little help.
But he's like, no, he knows what he's doing.
He's like a master of his domain.
His hidden secret is his skill at editing.
So we had some help on this film,
Angus wall, I don't know if you know Angus wall,
Uh uh.
But he's David Fincher's editor.
Oh wow.
So he edited Fight club,
he edited The Social Network.
He won some Academy award for that.
He edited, what's the one with,
what's the other big one he did?
I know it's on the tip of my tongue too.
Girl With The Dragon Tattoo.
He did the opening sequence to that.
Anyway, his company did the animation in Less Is Now.
And he was actually, we were gonna bring him
and that team on to edit the film.
But Matt was just like, "No, I'm good.
"I got it covered."
And that's the thing,
the weird thing about it is I don't think
Matt likes editing at all
but that is his hidden,
he's the Mozart of editing.
And he, even when we went from fourth cut to fifth cut,
Angus saw it and he was like,
"This looks like it went through 60 different
"cuts of the film."
Yeah, kudos to him.
So the movie explodes
and you guys kind of ride this wave.
You have the books and you started the podcast.
You're now 10 years into this thing.
You've got millions of people all over the world
that care deeply about the things that you talk about.
And what's really cool and compelling
about this platform that you now manage
is that it's completely audience supported.
You start all your podcasts, advertisements suck.
And you have this population of people
that adore you and basically
are willing to subscribe to your wisdom.
And you've been able to craft out
making a living off of this for a decade.
Most of what we do is free and available to the public.
And there's a small portion where we sort of dive deeper.
And our private podcast is on Patreon.
And yeah, we do have an audience that supports us there
but that's also, it's almost like when you go to,
well, back when we could go to the Comedy Store
or places like that
where people sort of work out ideas.
We work out things.
And sometimes Ryan and I just argue
on the private podcast about things
because we don't agree about something
or we bring a guest on and we argue with them about it.
I like to think of it as talking things out.
(all laugh)
But most of what we do is,
whether it's the blog or the main podcast,
it's accessible to anyone.
When you were touring, how many cities did you do?
I mean, you guys invited me to come
when you did the Fillmore in San Francisco,
which was like, so cool, man.
You guys were filling theaters all across the country.
Yeah, you were at the Fillmore with us.
Super fun.
That was great.
I mean the most we've ever done was 100 cities,
119 events in one year.
Wow.
We canceled a tour last this year, 2020,
because of 2020.
For obvious reasons.
And yeah, we've done what nine tours in 10 years.
So anywhere from a few cities
like the Simply Southern Tour was three cities.
We went with Dave Ramsey's team
and did a small tour in the South.
To 100 cities everywhere in between.
But yeah, it just became a part of,
and by the way, all those tours were different as well.
Sometimes it's a podcast tour.
Sometimes we do a talk.
Sometimes we'll do book readings and book signings.
It kind of just depends on what's going on.
So Dave Ramsey features
pretty prominently in the new movie.
So how did that relationship develop?
How does he fit into the minimalist ecosystem?
His daughter really likes us.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
His daughter works for him.
She's a very talented author.
Her name is Rachel Cruz and she has a great YouTube show.
And she invited us to come on her YouTube show.
It's in Nashville and it's a whole production.
They have a whole studio set up there.
He has 1,000 employees at his compound.
It's a really impressive setup.
And they work really hard to teach financial literacy.
They're now being taught in 25%
of the high schools around the country,
the Dave Ramsey curriculum.
He has a whole team, like 100 people on that team.
His whole thing is about living fiscally responsible,
like not living outside of your means
and making sure that you're making prudent financial,
essentially conservative prudent financial disease.
Yeah, I feel like he's like
a minimalist finance guy basically,
because you know, minimalism,
it's funny when I first heard it
and heard about it and looked into it,
I kind of thought like it was this niche type thing.
And then once I got into it, I'm like,
oh, this can be applied to anything.
And I think Dave Ramsey essentially
applies minimalism to finances.
He's got some great financial advice.
His whole team though, they're great.
Anthony O'Neil, Chris Hogan.
The whole lot of them.
John Delony
Yeah, Ken.
So we're well into this pandemic cycle,
fraying at the edges
pandemic cycle
as we crawl towards 2021.
And I'm interested in how you're thinking
about the relationship between consumerism
and minimalism with this very specific moment,
the way that I'm kind of thinking
about it is that on the one hand,
nobody's going to the mall,
they're not shopping, they're at home.
So it's forcing people to perhaps be a little bit
more reflective about those habits on some level,
yet at the same time, we're all empowered by these tools.
And we're spending, these technological tools,
we're all in front of our screens way too much.
And that habituation to shopping
has just migrated to the devices.
I don't know what the statistics are but I suspect,
I'm certain that online shopping has skyrocketed
but has consumerism overall increased during this moment?
How are you thinking about people's habits?
What does that look like right now?
It depends what we mean by consumerism.
So I do think consumerism is the right way to frame it.
That is one of the problems.
Consumption isn't the problem.
We talk about this in Less Is Now
because we all need to consume some stuff.
Consumerism, which is what we could just identify
as compulsory consumption in a way
as though we feel that we must buy this
in order to either be complete,
Ryan talked about the deficit advertising earlier,
or the what else is Annie call it in the film?
The vertical integration.
And so no longer are you just competing
with your next door neighbor.
Yeah, talk about that.
That's a really fascinating, important idea, I think.
So here's the new problem.
Consumerism is one problem when we relate that to stuff,
materialism is really that,
the other side of consumerism is distraction, I think.
And so the thing that Ryan and I will say
is scrolling is the new smoking.
And this epiphany hit me when I was walking
outside of like a Chipotle or something.
I see someone outside in the cold,
like in the Midwest, scrolling on their phone,
cigarette in hand at the same time.
And it's not to judge that person,
it's to see myself in that person.
I don't smoke, but I could see,
my habits are showing.
And it's not just the smoking.
Now, 50 years ago everyone
sort of casually puffed cigarettes.
We'd be at this table right now,
just smoking, talking.
It'd be a cloud.
But you did that now, it would seem nutty.
If I just lit up a cigarette right now,
you wouldn't know how to respond to that.
The only person who could do that is Dave Chappelle,
by the way, but besides him, it would seem nutty.
And yet it doesn't seem that strange if I,
it would because of the three of us,
but at your average setting
if I were to pull out a phone
and just check it really quick,
but it's just as bothersome in many ways.
It's secondhand distraction.
And so I think over the last decade in particular,
what we've seen is a lot of new ways to distract ourselves.
Ryan and I distracted ourselves back
in the aughties and in the late '90s with stuff.
But now the distractions are digital
and they're right there.
And they're more enticing than ever.
The same thing happens.
In the material world,
it was high paid demographers, statisticians,
marketers, aggregating your eyeballs
onto their product or service.
Now, since you're the product,
it's aggregating your eyeballs onto the product
and service to sell you products and services.
And so in a weird way, a dystopian way,
it elevates the problem.
It amplifies the problem.
I mean, without a doubt,
and this is subject matter and terrain
that movies like the Social Dilemma go into at length.
It's not just enticing, it's truly addictive.
And it's designed to be that way.
The revelatory idea that I had not thought about before
until I saw your movie was this idea
of the kind of exponential expansion
of keeping up with the Joneses,
this consumerist impulse originally derived
from perhaps something genetic within us
to try to keep pace with our neighbors.
So-and-so's got that refrigerator or that car,
I've got to get that too.
But now by dint of these technological tools,
everybody's our neighbor.
So it's not just the person living next door,
but it's the celebrity on Instagram
and you get to peek into their world,
or now on Zoom, you get to see
what everybody's study and living room looks like.
And it's almost impossible to not run that comparison
against what you have or don't have.
And how does that impact your consumer choices
or your sense of innate discontent
when you attempt to measure yourself
against that impossible standard?
Yeah, I think comparison is the killer of joy,
regardless of how you're comparing yourself
or what you have to other people.
It is interesting, like with the whole social media,
it's like, my sister,
when I was in Ohio a year ago,
you know, back when we were traveling without any fear.
She was like, "Do you feel cool,
"'cause you got, you know, X amount
"of subscribers on Instagram?"
And I'm like, "No."
I was like, "Do you think I'm cool
"because I have that many subscribers?"
And she's like, "Yeah, I think it's pretty cool."
And I'm like, "If you're looking at subscribers,
"I don't even know what I have.
"I know it's not a million", but I'm like,
"If you got to where I'm at
"with however many subscribers,
"then you'd be looking at a million,
"and then once you had a million
"you'd be looking at 3 million."
It's like a never ending comparison wheel
that we put ourselves on.
It's failure.
In a weird way, all success is failure.
So what are the tactics that you deploy
to prevent yourself from indulging
in that kind of fruitless mental exercise.
'Cause it's hard, right?
Yeah, it is.
I mean, I don't look at specific numbers.
That's one way.
Because I think, I'm a numbers guy in general.
I love math, I love spreadsheets.
So I could very easily get wrapped up into it
just to like make a game out of it.
But I try to not gamify it as much as possible
but I'll be honest, because of,
man, this is gonna sound like some
Buddhist hybrid thing,
but because of how destructive
my ego was in the corporate world,
anytime I start to feel the ego kicking in,
which it kicks in all the time,
but when I start to feel it kicking in
with like, oh, how many subscribers that I gained today?
Or how many?
'Cause I did feel that in the early days,
I try not to stroke that ego.
And by practicing that over the last 10 years,
I am able to just kind of still feel
like I felt 10 years ago.
I don't feel any more popular or successful.
I mean, even, it's funny,
you were talking about us
having a lot of people who adore us,
I think is what you said,
and they're willing to support us.
And I appreciate those people so much
but like hearing you say it,
my ego is like, oh wow, that is amazing.
We do have all these people who adore us
and who will support us.
So I guess just to reiterate,
when my ego starts to get out of control
I will try to like put it in check a little bit
because ultimately,
I know if I ever start to play that game,
it'll never be enough.
Yeah.
I don't have any tactics.
You guys aren't getting into Twitter spats
and things like that.
You seem to just, I can tell by the way
that you share your content online
that it's kind of at an arms length.
You make sure that your stuff is being shared
but you're not in there
going back and forth with people and stuff like that
A healthy detachment.
I'm not the Buddha.
The Buddha would be non-attachment right.
But not needing the outcome
and not needing any of it, by the way.
By being attached detached you realize that,
this is gonna sound like a value judgment,
but it's not, it's all a scam, man.
Who cares?
It's all ego.
Even by the way, what have I changed my mind about recently?
Helping people.
I don't want to help people.
Let's be honest, helping people,
that's just my ego saying I want to help people.
Now, I feel it's still viscerally
because I've programmed myself.
You will be externally validated
if you say that out loud
Right, right, it's my, no, no, no, no, no.
But maybe the truth behind that is I want peace.
I want to speak the truth.
And if that helps some people, that's wonderful.
If it doesn't, it can still be wonderful.
I don't need that.
Because once I become attached
to needing to help someone, it's a different type of prison.
It's a well decorated prison cell
but it's still a prison cell.
You can help people for selfish reasons though too,
'cause it makes you feel good.
It actually makes you
100%.
It gives your life a little bit more meaning
and it it builds self-esteem.
So even if your impetus, your impulse is selfish,
it's still a good thing to follow through on.
By the way,
I'm not saying that helping people is good or bad.
And also not helping people
is not good or bad by default then.
I don't want to throw that judgment out there.
I'm simply saying that I have to be honest with myself
that it's my ego that's involved
or where I'm like, it is what Ryan said.
If I have 10 million Instagram followers,
I'm helping more people.
Well, is that the truth or is that just a statistic?
I feel like there's two interesting things
happening right now,
which is the undeniable rise of popularity
around minimalism and related ideas.
There is a groundswell of people
who are feeling disconnected and dissatisfied in a way
and are discovering this way of living
that is giving their lives greater meaning and purpose.
But in tandem with that,
we're also seeing this acceleration
of our materialistic consumer culture.
You see it in the film too,
the kind of rapidisation of home delivery,
and Amazon, and the drones and you know how everything
just seems like it's on steroids right now,
almost like this war of ideas
that are bumping up against each other.
Well, you also see the sort of corporatization
of simplicity as well.
When Marie Kondo is selling
things at the Container Store.
It could be co-opted
And yeah, exactly.
The container store is actually one
of the biggest problems.
The container store allows us to hide our hoards.
And this isn't an indictment on Marie Kondo.
I think she really does get to the why in her book,
The Life Changing Magic of Tidying Up.
She obviously discusses the how to stuff.
That's her shtick, but she gets to the why.
But when I see tuning forks for several hundred dollars
and crystals and the commodification of simplicity,
well, you don't need anything to simplify.
Organizing is just well-planned hoarding.
And the thing we talked about the film
is the average American household has 300,000 items in it.
Now, I had a really organized version of that.
I had a basement full of bins and boxes
and ordinal alphabetized system of CDs and DVDs.
But it was just well, planned hoarding.
The easiest way to organize your stuff
is to get rid of anything
that's no longer adding value.
Get rid of most of it,
it's so much easier to quote unquote organize,
because you don't have anything that you have to organize.
You're getting to the essence
and you're stop worrying about the form.
I love that quote that you shared recently.
Everything is 100% off if you don't buy it.
(all chuckling)
I think we shared that maybe on black Friday
or something like, yeah.
Man I wish I could've told my 25 year old self that.
He may have not been ready for it though.
No.
You said something real briefly
about minimalism bringing meaning to people's lives.
And actually, I don't know if minimalism
brings meaning to people's lives.
I think it's minimalism helps someone
Etch-a-Sketch a new life.
It helps them start over.
And then from there they can start to do meaningful things.
And that's really what Less Is Now is about.
It's about being able to start over.
Thanks.
However you phrased it made me think
of it in a way of, I don't think minimalism is
Like getting it wrong.
Right.
I mean, I was alluding to that,
but yeah, I hear what you're saying.
No, that's a very good point.
The question I was gonna ask
was what would you tell yourself
five years ago when you were
well into the minimalism thing
that you understand better now
that maybe you didn't then as you kind of mature?
Five years ago
Drop the prescriptions.
Not the actual medical prescription, but
You mean back to the how to thing.
Yeah, but also
the desire to give advice to people,
that's also an ego thing.
I have no more advice.
I have some observations,
if you want to hear my own observations about my own life.
But even then going back and giving advice
to my 35 year old self would be almost counterintuitive.
Now, if I could show him some things,
it'd be the peace that's related to letting go
of some of the attachments,
because I think Ryan and I,
we picked up new attachments along the way,
especially when that film came out.
Talk about serving your ego.
When you get recognized on the street a dozen times a day
all of a sudden you start to believe
that you're better than what you are.
And Ryan and I, for a period of time,
I think we went three years
without doing any media as a result.
I was just, it doesn't feel good to need this.
And because it feels like you're creating
for the wrong reason.
It feels as though it's that externality
you talked about.
Well, that's a healthy dose of self-awareness.
Maybe.
I'm still working on eradicating that.
Aren't we all.
If you ever figure it out, let me know.
But that's the thing.
I don't think we ever figure it out.
I think it is the eradication thing.
You don't figure out heart disease,
you try to eradicate it in a way.
So the first movie came out in 2016.
What year was that?
Yeah, so Netflix actually
turned us down twice on that film.
So we put out on our own, we did a theatrical release
through a company called Gather at the time.
I don't even know if they're still around
but it was like theatrical on demand.
Was that 2016?
Yeah, that was May, 2016.
And we did 400 theaters, US, Canada, Australia.
And then from there we went back to Netflix.
They said, no, again.
And so we just put it out on our own
and it did relatively well.
It resonated with people on iTunes,
and Amazon, and other places.
And so Netflix ended up saying yes to it.
And that really started the conflagration
because we sent the rest of our audience there
who had been listening to the podcast
or reading the blog, and sparked whatever algorithm does.
And it showed up on a lot more people's radar.
I think that's how we showed up on your radar.
Yeah, I think so.
Well, I think you were doing a few podcasts
so I saw you guys popping up
on some friends and people that I knew.
And then I saw the movie.
I was very struck by the movie.
And then we did one of our retreats
in Italy and we screened it
for the group that we had there,
which was really cool.
That's cool.
I was just remembering that today.
That's awesome.
And I can't remember whether I did that,
I think I had interviewed you and then we went on the trip
or maybe I interviewed you right afterwards.
I can't remember.
But I just remember being very moved by that film.
And then we did the podcast and I believe
that you might've even alluded either on mic or off
that you guys were working on another documentary.
We were.
Like there was gonna be a follow-up.
And here we are five, maybe almost six years later
before Less Is Now premiers.
So what happened?
We ran into some technical difficulties.
Well, Ryan and I, shortly after that came out
we went to Matt again and we did another tour.
It was called The Less Is Now Tour.
And we went out filming that,
trying to sort of recreate the magic of the first film.
And we put it together.
We actually, we did an event at the Wilbur Theater.
This where Joe Rogan shot his most recent comedy special.
Beautiful spot.
Yeah, we filmed it, we gave a talk there,
and we were going to sort of build
the film around that talk.
And we kind of ended up doing that
in this later version of the film.
And the talk looked fine
but it kind of looked like a stand-up comedy special
without comedy.
You were like waiting for the punch,
because it was the venue.
And so it just, it fell flat.
It didn't work.
And so we did it again.
We actually brought you out,
we rented out this giant warehouse space.
That was like two years ago.
Almost three, yeah.
Matt was there, there was tons of,
was it that long ago?
Almost three
Almost three, yeah.
And this was the big shoot.
Yeah, it was 2018
And you had a live audience.
I mean, that warehouse space is in the movie.
Was that from that evening
No.
or did you guys end up re-shooting that?
That was from a year and a half later.
A year and a half later we went to the same studio.
Wow.
'Cause I was telling Julie,
we were watching it, and I was like,
"Yeah, I was there that night
"when these guys were doing this.
"but, I'm like, "it doesn't look like there's people there.
"Like when I was there, there was a lot of people there.
"So something was weird."
Yeah, something was different about it.
Yeah, so it went from a comedy special,
to no comedy, to a really well done TEDx Talk.
That's what it looked like.
So that night you were there, you actually came up
you're gracious enough to do the intro for us.
And we gave a talk in front of two different crowds
because we figured,
well the Wilbur Theater aesthetic was the problem.
And so we'll refilm this in front of a beautiful aesthetic,
this old abandoned warehouse,
we'll build the set for it, bring a crew out, film it.
And it'll work out that way.
That's the problem.
Well then, so we get there
and then we start interspersing it
with these documentary elements.
And it was like mixing vegan cheesecake,
shout out to Rich Roll, and sweet and sour tofu
and just mushing them two together.
And you're like, I really like both of these things
but they don't work when I smash them together.
And so we had to go back to the drawing board
and we said, hey, we're just going to scrap.
So that was the second time we did the film.
We scrapped the whole thing and started over again.
And so this project we thought
was gonna take us about four months
ended up taking about four years from the inception until.
'Cause when I was there that night
my sense was that you guys were
in the final throes of wrapping this thing up.
Oh, we were, of that version.
And those two will never see the light of day.
It's not that they were terrible.
They just didn't work
for what we were trying to communicate.
We knew
we weren't really putting our best foot forward.
As Ryan said, it was like
it would've been a really good YouTube video.
Yeah, it would've been a great YouTube video.
I was just gonna say, just to add onto that,
when we got those two films back,
I just remember not getting the feeling
that I got with Minimalism.
For what we gave Matt, he did an amazing job,
for what we gave him.
But yeah, it's been a long road.
Well, it's tough too,
because the first one had a built-in narrative
and you guys are these underdogs
and you're going on this trip.
So there's kind of a tempo or a propulsion to that.
And in the follow-up,
then the challenge is like, well,
what's the next chapter of this
and how do we make that compelling?
I think that chapter ended up being the chapter before
like it was in a weird way,
it was the first ever documentary prequel.
It doesn't require you to see the first film, obviously.
Yeah, not at all.
And they're two independent things.
And this one, we were really aggressive
about keeping it under an hour
in the whole spirit of minimalism.
But in doing that, we had to cut out a lot of amazing.
Ryan had this whole sub narrative about this.
We can talk about it here.
'Cause you haven't really talked about it publicly.
The whole drug thing.
I was like you, Rich, I loved to party.
This is something that I know about you
but I've never heard you actually talk about.
You've had your run in with drugs and alcohol.
For sure.
I talk about it whenever it comes up
like I'm totally okay to talk, especially coming from Ohio.
'Cause like I hope someone in Ohio
who is hooked on pain pills right now
is listening to this and knowing
that they can totally pull themselves out of that situation.
'Cause I mean, Dayton, Ohio, where we're from,
I don't know if it still is,
but it was the overdose capital of the world.
So there's just a lot of drugs there.
But yeah, to Josh's point,
there was this beautiful arc in the film
that we couldn't put in there
that I really tried to get.
And Matt tried to put it, it just didn't work.
But it was about kind of going down that road
and what pain that caused me
and how I was able to kind of start over.
But it's really, it's those stories,
again, unfortunately it couldn't make the film,
but I think it's those stories
that really mean the most to people.
They want to hear about,
oh, Ryan isn't this perfect person
who is just one day like, oh I'm gonna simplify my life.
And I mean, it was a lot of work,
and it was a lot of pain,
and it was a lot of discomfort,
And I did get through it,
but yeah, I was living in the, is it an opiate?
Is that what pain pills are?
They're opiates?
Many of them are.
So yeah, opiates were real easy access.
And when I was working 60, 70,
sometimes 80 hours a week, I would caffeinate myself.
I didn't do a lot of coke,
mainly because my mom like turned me off
to that drug because I saw her go through her own thing.
And I talk about that in the first documentary.
But I would caffeinate myself, Adderall,
whatever productivity thing I could get in my body.
But then you get home at nine o'clock at night
and it's hard to unwind,
but it's really easy with a pain pill and a beer and yeah.
So I got kinda trapped in that.
So it wasn't going out to the bars and getting loaded.
It was more.
It was some of that too.
Right, okay, I feel better.
Unfortunately, we even did recreation scenes
of Ryan getting beat up at a bar once,
that didn't make the film.
We're actually gonna find a way to put a lot
of this on Patreon or somewhere.
I actually just got permission
from Netflix today to use some of these scenes somewhere.
And Ryan talked about it in the film
but like we're spending upwards of $5,000 a month
I remember telling him
On opioids,
I'm like, I might have a problem.
I was talking to my therapist about it,
and I remember mentioning that to them.
And she was like, "Eh",
She's like, "I've seen worse.
"I've seen people spending $10 to $15,000
"a month on drugs."
Time for a new therapist.
Yeah, right.
She's like, "You're not that bad."
I think he was just trying to make me not feel so bad.
So did you just go cold turkey
Oh no.
and put it in the rear view
or how did you get past it?
I went through it.
I probably should have done a 12 step program,
but I went off of opiates to get on,
there's a product called like
Suboxone?
Suboxone, yeah.
And you don't really, it's not like methadone.
Methadone is something that you just go
from illegal addictions to legal addictions,
where Suboxone works a little bit different in the brain.
So I was on that program for a little bit,
getting a lot of therapy.
And I remember one time I was going on a trip
and I had forgot to bring my Suboxone
and I went like two weeks without it.
And I was like, oh, I'm free.
I'm done.
I don't have to do this anymore.
And you just never went back.
Never went back, yeah.
Wow.
Yeah, man.
Good for you, man.
Yeah, it was a long road.
I wouldn't wish that experience on my worst enemy.
The detox from opioids is horrible.
It's miserable.
I still don't think I've recovered 100%.
Like mentally, you mean, like brain function wise?
Sleep wise, I think.
Yeah your deep sleep's still way off, right?
Yeah, I'm lucky to get like
You guys are both rocking the Oura ring, I can tell.
Yeah.
So yeah, it was a long road,
but when I started living intentionally
and really facing these things head on,
that wasn't the magic answer
but it certainly gave me some leverage.
Well, alluding to something
that I asked you about earlier.
I mean, both of you guys survived
quite a bit of childhood trauma.
Are you in therapy?
How have you worked through?
You seem to have a pretty healthy
relationship with your past now.
It doesn't feel like you're holding onto
a lot of resentment
No.
and those kinds of negative patterns.
So how did you work through that?
I think trauma's perspectival in many ways.
Like I talk about this in the film.
So my very first memory as a child
is my father extinguishing a cigarette on Mom's chest.
Now of course, I'm going to remember something like that.
That's horrible.
But I also don't think it traumatized me
the same way that other things trauma.
And so, it's weird.
Like I do remember that
and I'm sure it was awful or whatever
but there are other things that seem less consequential
but traumatized me even more.
I was much more worried
of Child Protective Services taking me away
because my mom was an alcoholic.
I think I was far more traumatized by that.
I certainly have a lot of forms of sort of OCD.
I've been diagnosed with OCD, but it's like low level.
I'm not like painting my floor every day
or anything like that.
But I'm sure that's a whole thing about control,
because of the chaos of childhood.
It's almost like you have this bar of like,
well, I'm not painting my floor.
Yeah.
But just like anything
you can have an unhealthy relationship to a good thing.
I'm sure that you could have an unhealthy relationship
to minimalism where it is,
I am absolutely in control of my environment all the time.
The solution becomes the problem.
And that's why the whole anti prescription thing
for me now.
Yeah, I've been doing a lot more
exploration this year around around that.
But
we don't actually need the solutions.
If your chair's on fire right now, Rich,
you're not gonna say, hey,
can you hand me that fire safety manual over there?
Because it would really help me out right now.
You don't need three steps to get out of a flaming chair.
You're going to do it
and you're gonna do it like that
because your why is so powerful,
the how takes care of itself.
And so the problem is not a lack of instructions.
The problem is that your butt is on fire.
And so I think that too often we,
any answer I give you here
will sort of be like a narrative overlay
with respect to the trauma or whatever.
But I think it does have to do with detachment ultimately.
And maybe there's a healthy detachment
and unhealthy detachment.
I don't know, but a healthy detachment from,
I don't cling to that anymore.
I'm so glad you asked this question
about our childhoods,
because I did hold on to a lot of resentment
for my mother and father.
And it was mainly because I felt kind of gypped
of like, why would they do those things?
Why didn't they?
They're the parents, I'm the child.
They should be able to know what to do.
And any normal parent would put their child first.
And I had all these narratives
and all these questions.
And through therapy,
and I got to this recently within the last few years,
I mean, I've always tried to have
a good relationship with my parents with that resentment,
but I was able to let a lot of it go when,
it was a couple of years ago,
seeing a therapist here in LA,
and he just kind of helped me get to this point
of when things really started to hit the fan,
my parents were probably 30, maybe 32,
they're younger than I am now.
That's a trip when you realize that.
Yeah, it is, it was.
And I was like, wait a minute,
here I am with this narrative of like
they should have known what to do.
And I'm like, I'm 37 years old.
I have no idea what the hell I'm doing.
And for me to put that pressure on them wasn't fair.
I didn't see it as fair.
And I finally looked at them.
I'm like, oh.
'Cause you know, I'd love to sit here, Rich,
and be like, oh, I've got a perfect life.
Become a minimalist and you're gonna live a perfect life.
But I still struggle with a lot of things.
And I've got my own battles that I'm fighting.
And my parents, I finally was able to see,
like, oh, they've got their own shit going on.
They've got their own battles that they're fighting.
And they're still fighting them to this day.
And I'm really glad I don't have those battles.
However, understanding that I'm 39 years old.
I'm for all intents and purposes,
just as confused as they were at 32 years old.
And seeing that in them really helped me
drop those poor me, why me,
why didn't they, they should have,
it really helped me drop a lot of that.
Right, right, right.
And that those behaviors aren't necessarily
a referendum on how much they loved you or didn't love you.
Absolutely.
But just their own personal limiters, it?
God, it felt like it at the time.
When I was 30, I was a disaster.
You and me both.
It definitely felt like it at the time though,
growing up, like, if you loved me, you'd stop drinking
sort of thing.
And yeah.
Ryan and I grew up in similar sort of situations.
I would argue his situation was far worse than mine
in many respects.
No way.
Let's battle right now on.
The SWAT Team never raided my home.
Oh yeah, that's true.
All right, you got me.
That's heavy, man,
that's heavy.
But what I'll say is that Ryan saw the partying
growing up as a fun thing.
He saw his Mom in particular
having fun with drugs and alcohol.
I saw my mother being depressed with drugs and alcohol.
I've never had a drink in my life
because I saw the sort of terminus of this thing.
Where Ryan saw what he thought was the terminus,
the excitement, the joy, the pleasure.
It wasn't real joy.
It was confusing joy with pleasure.
Yeah, Mom's house was like the party house.
I remember people would just pop in random.
We had a pool and like fenced in backyard.
But it was an above ground pool.
Yeah, but good times.
Right, exactly.
But that's all you needed
and a bunch of drugs and alcohol
and everyone's having a good time.
So it's fascinating to me that you guys
have best friends since fifth grade.
You're now in 10 years of doing this thing together,
so you're in business together.
I've never seen you guys argue or act short with each other.
You must have your moments.
I mean, come on.
But I mean, how have you,
how do you take care of this relationship?
The Minimalists exposed.
How do you make sure that you guys
are good with each other?
It's gotta be challenging at times.
I think Josh is the most tolerant person I know.
So he's just able to put up with all my crap.
That's what it is.
That's what it is, it has nothing to do with me.
It's a joke.
We have an acronym that we often talk about.
Shout out to Patrick Roan who had the conversation with us
that spurred this acronym.
It's Tara, TARA.
But if I really want to understand someone,
truly understand them,
that's the sort of the process that I go through
of tolerating the person first.
It's a weak virtue and it's not
gonna get you very far.
Tolerance.
There's a, what is it on the I-10
whenever we're driving an Ella
is acting crazy in the car.
There's a sign that says museum of tolerance.
And I always joke with Ella,
The Robertson.
that our car is the museum of tolerance
whenever she's in the car.
The mobile museum of tolerance anyway.
Anyway, tolerate.
And then we go from there,
we take these, these steps.
Tolerance is a good first step.
And then we move on to acceptance,
respect, and then ultimately appreciation.
And Ryan and I have radically different beliefs.
I'm trying to let go of those beliefs.
I don't think beliefs serve us very well
but that's a different conversation.
We have the same values though.
And because we have the same values,
when we have different beliefs,
so we get there via different paths, so to speak.
We have different opinions.
We have different personalities.
We certainly have different preferences.
But I don't say, well,
his preferences are right or wrong.
I might think it at first,
but that's also my ego talking
and I don't want to just tolerate his preferences.
That's not gonna make for a good friendship,
a good business relationship.
And by the way, it doesn't ever feel like a business.
I don't think we had business paperwork
until about four years into the thing.
Even now we don't have,
it's not something we think about that way.
Yeah, it's a business, we employ some people,
but we go beyond tolerance.
We accept the fact that we're both gonna be different.
I'm not trying to change you.
It's not about, here's what you must do.
And then of course the respect thing
of course I respect your preferences.
I don't always completely understand them, but that's okay.
And ultimately, if you can get to that level
where you actually appreciate the idiosyncrasies
then that's like full sort of detachment,
not needing to change someone
I think, and this goes for any relationship.
First off, if Josh comes to me with something,
it's not accusatory,
it's like something he wants to talk about.
And when you approach a situation like that,
you can interpret it a lot differently
than like, oh Josh is trying to shame me.
I never feel like he's trying to shame me.
And I think that is where arguments come in.
When people start to try and shame other people
and that's, oh you just shamed me,
now I'm gonna shame you.
And now we're gonna trade shames back and forth.
Where I try to be the Zen Buddhist
that Josh is when it comes to confrontation,
but sometimes I'll go to Josh with something
and he'll be like,
"I know you don't mean to say it that way.
"I think what you're trying to say is this.
And I'm like, "Yeah, you're absolutely right."
And so when I say it's Josh, it truly is,
when he comes to me, it's absolutely non-confrontational.
And if I go to him
and I'm accidentally being confrontational
he's able to process it and be like,
I know Ryan's not being a jerk right now.
So yeah, let's get to the root of
That's some ninja shit though.
It's hard to master that
and have that kind of presence of mind.
It's really inspiring.
Like for me and my wife,
I really go out of my way
to try and have that approach with her.
Again, I'm not perfect, but I do better.
Every day I get a little better, I think.
I used to be competitive
but that's like saying I used to be mentally ill.
I was doing a sauna in Montana
when we lived in Montana for five years
as a accident, and a beautiful accident.
Some nice photos from that though,
came out of that.
Yeah, we did it for the photos, did it for the gram.
You did not do it for the gram.
I don't think we even had Instagram.
But anyway, I was in a sauna
with an American Indian named Tom.
And there's like a basketball court right next to sauna.
It's the YMCA in Missoula.
And the swimming and all this other stuff.
And he goes, "You know, I don't understand you Americans,
"you have this, this idea of in order for you to win,
"you have to lose."
He's like, "But where I come from, if you win, he wins.
"And if he loses you lose."
And of course my first knee jerk reaction
to that was like, that's a silly way to think about life,
because I'm winning.
And it's like, well, no,
You just haven't won enough, that's your problem.
Yeah, but think about that.
We talk about winning.
Obviously Charlie Sheen is the parotic
exaggeration of that.
But that's not far off from where our culture is.
We talk about winning as though it's a good thing.
But by default, if someone wins, someone else has to lose.
Now, maybe it's a semantic thing
and we can change our language around it.
But I think language is really important.
I think it's a real big problem too
but I think our language,
it canvases our days.
Language is responsible for more misery
than anything else in human history.
Well, that idea, I mean,
the most successful people I know,
maybe not all of them
but I know a lot of successful people
who do approach the world with that idea of largess
that it's not a zero sum game.
And if I win, you win too.
And not only are you able to basically
succeed in whatever it is that you're trying to do.
Those people tend to be much happier people
and grounded and more conscious in general.
You had the Tom's guy on recently, Blake?
Yeah, Blake.
He strikes me as that.
He's definitely someone like that.
I also had Karamo from Queer Eye on
and he was talking about the audition process for Queer Eye.
And they spent like years trying to find
the four dudes that do the show.
And most of the guys were super competitive
and they'd go in and audition.
And then they come out and the other guys would be like,
"What'd they ask you?"
And they wouldn't say,
'cause they're like, I'm competing against you.
I'm not gonna tell you any secrets.
But there were a couple of them
that would come out and be like,
here's what happened, here's what you need to look out for.
And those were the guys that ultimately
all ended up getting chosen
Wow.
For the show
That's incredible
which obviously changed their lives
and the lives of a lot of people that watch that show,
Interesting.
which is cool.
That is cool
I love that idea.
It makes me think of Google,
when they hire people they bring them on a bus
and then whether or not they thank the bus driver
is like a huge, it's like a litmus test.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's interesting.
Like, how do you behave when no one's watching?
Because in this context there were casting people
who are paying attention to this behavior.
And it's like, we want people that approach the world
with that kind of arms outstretched perspective
of gratitude and giving
Amen.
And to reward that.
We were talking about Dave Ramsey earlier
his team, they interview the spouse
in one of the interviews,
it's a rather rigorous process
but your spouse gets interviewed as well, separately.
And it's fascinating to me because I think
maybe they're like trying to figure out,
how do you handle conflict?
How do you make decisions?
How do you make some of your biggest life choices?
Are they congruent with the person
that we want to to hire?
Now I can imagine that might be a train wreck
for some people, but I know if you interviewed Becks,
I would totally get the job no matter what the job was.
(all laughing)
How do you know what she's gonna say?
You think you know.
Let's talk a little bit more about the movie.
I mean, I came into this thinking
these guys have been working on this thing for years,
because I know how long ago it was
when I was there at that event.
But you are featuring these individuals,
the kind of everyday people,
minimalist people that are highlighted
in the movie and they're on Zoom calls.
So I was like, well, clearly
you're executing this project during the pandemic.
The pandemic was the best and worst thing
that happened in this film.
So we had this entire day set up in Los Angeles.
We had a whole crew booked.
We had location and we were bringing
I don't know what it was, 22 or 32 people
in to be interviewed that day
the majority of them were these everyday minimalists.
In fact, I think it was a two day shoot early or mid March.
Of course, you know what happened.
Right at the beginning,
the starting line of the whole thing.
But the original thing that we wanted to do was,
have you seen YouTube reaction videos
when people sort of react to a music video
or they react to a product or service or something?
I might've seen one or two of those.
So we kind of wanted to do that,
but with minimalism in a way.
And so it was Chris's idea.
Chris is our director of photography on the film.
And so that actually worked out better
by bringing us sort of into their homes in a way.
In fact, we had them do some B roll
of some of their houses,
that shows up in the film as well.
So you get to see the sort of decluttering process
they went through.
Some of them even had footage that they took
when they simplified their life a year or two ago.
And we got to include all of that in the film,
even though we filmed the rest of it in the studio
Well, it gives it in addition to this verite touch,
it's heartwarming because it's so authentic.
It's like, they're actually shooting it themselves
and sharing it as opposed to a sterilized film crew
coming in and trying to make everything look just so.
We sent them cameras and stuff.
So it looked congruent with,
each one didn't feel like it was out of place
but yeah, it was them doing the thing on their own.
Yeah, and we got most of the cameras back.
I'm just kidding.
We got them all back.
More stuff.
Talk to me about some of the other experts
that you have featured in here.
'Cause it's an interesting grouping of people.
In addition to Dave Ramsey,
you've got TK Coleman who I know
he was on your podcast not that long ago,
Annie Leonard from Greenpeace,
Denaye Barahona from Simple Families.
So she's kind of squarely in the minimalist space,
it feels like.
But it was intriguing,
like, oh, this person from Greenpeace,
she's about sustainability,
but I was interested in how you made these choices.
She did the story of stuff, if you recall.
She's the lady who did that video.
I mean, it's been seen probably 100 million times
at this point, The Story of Stuff.
That's weird, 'cause I saw her and I was like,
she looks really familiar.
There's an actress that looks kind of like her as well
but I couldn't put my finger on it.
Yeah, so she's an executive director of Greenpeace USA,
And yeah, so we only wanted five experts in the film
and we wanted them from these different perspectives.
So one was the environmental side of things.
There's obviously overlap with all of them.
We wanted the economic side of things.
So TK Coleman, he is an education director at FEE.
We had Dave Ramsey as sort of the money side of things,
the debt especially, how it's tied to consumerism.
Denaye Barahona, she runs an organization
called Simple Families,
and really focused on parenting and kids.
And so we wanted to bring the family side in there as well.
And we had Erwin McManus
who is a pastor here in Los Angeles,
who probably was, it's hard to pick a favorite,
but he had some of my favorite lines in the entire film.
He's an interesting dude.
' Cause wasn't he like a fashion designer
or something like that?
Yes.
He has this whole other, he's like a designer.
He does all this other stuff.
Yeah, and he still does.
He just launched a new, like super minimalist clothing line.
And he talks about intentional living
in ways that, they're just really profound.
And I was just really grateful to have that opportunity
to sit with him.
He's been on our podcast a couple of times to.
TK has been on our podcast.
I think you've been on there the second most.
TK has been on there maybe like eight times.
In fact, if I can introduce you to anyone,
TK, he'll blow your socks off,
Oh cool.
the best person you could speak to
about just about anything,
but especially like economics.
But I'm unclear on his, like, so he's in education,
but I'm unclear about the nexus
between that and minimalism.
So he was sort of our economy expert in a way.
And I wanted to juxtapose,
you could call him a capitalist,
though that word doesn't really mean
what you would,
it's taken on a pejorative frame in the last five, 10 years,
but I wanted to juxtapose Annie
who has probably radically different beliefs
from TK and show that they overlap.
And it literally overlapped in the film together.
And even though they disagreed about some things,
where she talks about growth and infinite growth
and then he immediately sort of rebuts that
by talking about, I don't think the problem is growth.
And he goes into what he thinks the problem is.
And so we wanted some opinions that,
we didn't want it to be like the Yes Man show.
I wanted to learn something from these people.
And Erwin, he really helps solidify the theme of the film.
It's a film, as Ryan said earlier, about starting over.
He has a line in there
about the shaking the Etch-a-Sketch thing
that Ryan talked about,
but we should all, not should, there's no should.
We all have the opportunity.
I like how you caught yourself there.
Here's the most problem I have is like
I keep setting these things down, like the shoulds.
And then I have the pattern.
I pick them back up repeatedly.
We all have the opportunity though,
to restart our lives, to start over.
And this film was about starting over with less.
And that can be less stuff,
but it can also be less distractions,
fewer commitments, et cetera.
I love that.
Yeah.
What is the main idea that you want
people to take away from the film?
I mean, I think Josh said it,
it's about starting over.
I mean, is this film for every single person?
I think every single person will get something out of it
but I think who it's going to help the most
is someone who's in a situation right now
and they need some emotional leverage to start over.
I think this film will help them do that.
Just the nudge they need.
I don't think the film was for everyone,
as Ryan just said, but it's for anyone
who's sort of dissatisfied by the status quo
whatever status quo they've created for themselves.
We're overburdened.
And a lot of that has to do with stuff.
But I think it also has to do with toxic relationships.
I think it has to do with debt.
There are all these burdens, we've taken them on.
We've picked up all this baggage,
but we can also set it down.
It might take some time to set it down,
especially with debt.
In the first film, in Minimalism,
I talked about,
I had almost half a million dollars worth of debt.
I was making $200 grand a year in Dayton, Ohio
but I was spending like $220 grand a year,
whatever they would let me spend.
And so I had massive amounts of debt as a result.
And I had to sort of set that burden down.
It took some time, but you know,
the best way do that is to stop spending,
to stop whatever excess is going on.
We can't add our way to contentment,
to joy, to peace.
It's always about subtraction.
The timing is very interesting because we're all at home.
And I think with that comes a natural inclination
to do a little bit of inventory
on how we're living our lives
and what is our relationship to our job,
to our profession,
when you're not going into an office every day
or into a workplace in the manner
in which you're accustomed to,
that interruption of the flow or the routine
I think is triggering a lot of people
to be more reflective about how they're spending their time
and their resources, et cetera.
So to the point about the nudge
or the kind of gentle push towards these ideas,
I feel like people are primed for this now.
And it is a moment of radical change.
A lot of people are thinking about this
in terms of when are we gonna get back to the way it was.
It's not going back to the way it was.
We are forever altered.
Some things will normalize to a certain extent
but the idea that everyone's gonna migrate
back into office buildings, I think is lunacy.
That's not gonna happen.
We've now figured out how to pursue livings
from Zoom and these tools that we have.
So what does that look like down the line?
And how can we reflect on this
to reform our relationship with the outside world
so that it can be healthier
and it can be more fulfilling and more purposeful?
And the movie really speaks to that in a profound way.
And I think it's gonna help a lot of people.
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks.
Normal wasn't working for a lot of us
and this gave us the opportunity to realize that.
It was a forced pause for many of us
even for me and Ryan.
We had a whole tour planned this year
and the film was gonna come out earlier, et cetera.
And we had a bunch of speaking things
we were going to do.
There aren't corporations that are meeting,
so we couldn't go speak at these places.
And so it was a pause for us as well
but it's not to take away either
what some people are faced with.
My brother, he is back in Ohio, he works in a factory.
He worked in a factory building cabinets.
It was a well-paying job and he was talented and skilled.
And he was doing that.
That whole thing shut down.
It's not coming back.
He went and got part-time job at Amazon
so he could pay, feed his daughters.
And now he's working third shift at a meat packing plant
because that's like his only reality right now.
And talk about one of the most difficult jobs you could have
and doing it third shift, no less.
But so a lot of people are affected by this.
And so, while I don't want to go back to where we were,
I also don't want to see more suffering.
And so I think what's happening right now
is Ryan and I for the last decade
have been asking this question, what is essential?
And now a lot more people are all of a sudden asking it.
In fact, the term's even out there, essential worker, right.
But what is essential in my home?
What is essential in my life?
What is essential on my calendar?
What is essential?
And that's what I hope to illuminate with this film,
how people ask that question.
What is essential?
I think that's a good place to put a pin in it for now
until you guys come back next time.
Rich, I Love your brother.
Thank you so much.
You're awesome.
You guys too.
I have so much love for you guys as people
and respect for this mission
that you've shouldered for the world.
You guys are great servants to humanity
and it's a privilege to talk to you.
So thank you.
Right back at you, brother.
Wind in your sails, my friends.
Thank you, brother.
That means a lot.
Thank you so much.
Before we sign off, where's the best place
for people to learn more about you guys?
Where would you like them to connect?
In addition to obviously checking out
Less Is More on Netflix.
And also if you didn't see it the first time around,
Minimalism, the original movie.
Well, Ryan has an OnlyFans he just started.
I am so here for that.
You said you wouldn't say a word
about that on Rich's podcast.
Audience supported.
That's right.
So many people adore me.
Talk about minimalism, all right.
Just theminimalists.com.
You can find our podcasts, books, films, everything else.
It's all in one hub, theminimalists.com.
Nice, cool.
Thanks, you guys.
Thank you.
Peace.
See ya.
Thanks.